it's easy to get lost with all of the
twists in the turns in the Ukraine Gate
saga and a lot of you just have tuned it
out but no matter what road you go down
they all lead back to one person Trump's
personal attorney Rudy Giuliani his
investigations into corruption and what
the Biden's were up to in Ukraine are
what sparked much of this in the first
place
moreover Giuliani was in Ukraine earlier
this month continuing his investigation
that drove the left crazy and while he's
touting new evidence he says will
vindicate the president some critics
allege that Giuliani is actually hurting
the president more than he's helping can
that be true joining us now the man of
the moment Rudy Giuliani we thought
would ask you personally Rudy what is
your reaction to those critics who say
oh my gosh Rudy's got to stop while he's
behind they don't even say ahead
Rudy they're so critical of you well I
don't know maybe they don't believe that
there was in fact substantial corruption
in Ukraine that went on for years and
that the President of the United States
when he asked for an investigation was
doing his duty as the president of the
United States
maybe they buy into some form of the
democratic criticism but what I
uncovered there yeah are two major
schemes one for 7.5 billion the other
for 5 billion in money laundering that
went on all through the Obama
administration part of it involves Joe
Biden the bribery part it's a disgrace
that he's not under investigation for it
in America maybe because our law
enforcement is too afraid but the
reality is it's a complete defense for
the president when the president arrives
States was asking the president of
Ukraine to investigate he was asking him
to investigate crimes at the highest
levels of both governments that the
president of the Ukraine referred to as
we meaning it's our problem joint
problem so he's being impeached for
doing the right thing as president of
the United States nothing to be
defensive about Rudy much work your work
in Ukraine hinges on the word of former
prosecutor general of the Ukraine
Senko here's how he was described in The
New Yorker of course no conservative
publication but you gave them an
interview
Lutz Anka sometimes referred to simply
as the corrupt prosecutor general of
Ukraine has been portrayed hardly
without reason as an unscrupulous
politician prone to telling lies to
further his personal ambitions
Lysenko fed information to Giuliani
which Giuliani Trump and their allies
spun to smear the reputations of the
Biden's and Murray Ivanovich Jim Trump
fired in April one of the houses star
witnesses told of lysenko said I don't
think we'd be here if not for him now
this hit piece and it's a hit piece of
course also has you on the record
admitting that you forced out murray
ivanovitch did you needed her out of the
way but you're a personal attorney for
the president so why do you need her out
of the way i didn't need her out of the
way i've I forced her out because she's
corrupt I came back with a document that
will show unequivocally that she
committed perjury when she said that she
turned down the visa for mr. Shogun
because of corruption the fact is on the
record in the State Department's own
records the reason given is because he
had had an operation and hadn't
recovered yet the operation of course
was two years before its documentary
evidence that she committed perjury I
have four witnesses who will testify
that she personally turned down their
visas because they were going to come
here and give evidence either against
Biden or against the Democratic Party
there's no question that she was acting
corruptly in that position and had to be
removed she should have been fired if
the State Department worm part of the
deep stage but I have a question Pompeyo
is someone I know you have an enormous
amount of respect for Secretary of State
you know I certainly do why not you know
why doesn't the president go to Pompeo
and say we have concerns I want my own
person and that's just normal presidents
put their own people and all the time
big deal so why doesn't it go from from
the President to Pompeo why does it go
from you would you go it didn't go from
me to the president first one to go to
the president with Pete sessions and
then a number of congressmen who said
that she was saying that he's
be impeached and then when I interviewed
witnesses not just mr. luchenko for
other witnesses they told me that she
was specifically holding up visas in
order to obstruct the investigation of
collusion in the Ukraine and
specifically to obstruct the Biden
investigation I have that testimony
under oath I gave it to the State
Department they never investigated a
single witness when they say that she's
innocent it's innocent without
investigation oh yeah what'd they say
Rudy
well there's a cover-up yeah what'd they
say the entire hearing she was saying
well I'm the one and everyone else who
knew her she was there fighting
corruption she was inside he was just
pushing the envelope I also have tape
recordings with Ukrainian officials
including career prosecutors who say
that during the Obama era the corruption
in Ukraine became substantially worse
and that she was a contributor to the
corruption for example remember remember
when she was asked at the end by Jim
Jordan about how many things the
Ukrainians had done the statements that
were made that he should be destroyed
his campaign should be destroyed he was
insane the the Ambassador from McRae of
the US criticized she was asked did you
ever go complain about that to the
Ukrainian government this is foreign
interference in our election right the
answer was no also when she talks about
Shokan being corrupt how come she
doesn't talk about the candidates she
supported poroshenko who stole
everything that didn't move poroshenko
is right now under investigation for
taking 100 million dollars in bribes my
question is a deeper with him yeah I
didn't was close to him if they were
worried about corruption why weren't
they worried about your friend billions
Ukraine wanted Hillary to win and that's
just beyond obvious I've got a couple
countries want her to win
we know that Rudie Rudie hot people in
the White House today according to these
reporters who are talking on on camera
are worried about your continuing role
fairly or unfairly Jonathan Karl watch
I'm if you talk to senior officials in
the White House to a person privately
they will tell you that they did they
wish Rudy Giuliani would just go away
and never be seen in public again
related to any of this there's great
frustration is that in any way an ear
view accurate are there people in the
White House that was saying that that
could be is it accurate that in some way
it's gonna hurt to show the substantial
amount of corruption that took place and
that the president was doing what he
should do when he asked for an
investigation I'd say they're buying
into the democratic spin the the fact is
there's nothing to be defensive about
Joe Biden was involved in a
multi-million dollar corrupt scheme
along with a number of other Democrats
it's never been resolved they've never
been held to account as long as those
issues remain between the United States
and Ukraine we really can't fight
corruption in the Ukraine and the fact
is that there are numerous Ukrainian
witnesses that want to come to the
United States and explain how much
during the Obama administration Ukraine
was corrupted by Americans okay but Rudy
why are we giving them any money then
why did the president okay the money I
can't answer that question as to why
they do them all the time I wouldn't
give him a cent
my job is to defend of what I will tell
you is I have a report from the
Ukrainian counter no accounting office
in 2017 showing that 5.3 billion dollars
in aid seems to have been wasted our
State Department's let me finish rather
interrupting me so I got the whole
thought out our State Department under
Jovanovic went to the police and told
them not to do the investigation and
then they demanded they not do the
investigation you know why because our
embassy was involved in wasting a great
deal of that money by giving it to NGOs
and
I was asked to the do the NGOs have a
political bent you know the answer given
they were Soros like they will left of
left well I hope you have the president
and the Congress and the Senate right a
time but a Lindsey Graham and all these
guys actually do an investigation that's
not coming from you but that's coming
from a lot of this time did I am willing
to show this to anybody that wants to
pay attention to it so far
law enforcement has been afraid to look
at it yeah all right well we got--we if
someone's got to do that someone's gonna
actually do this so this is if this is
going to make sense to people and really
make sense then it actually has to be
followed through by the appropriate
channels you're one person and a lawyer